therefore it's back and this year I'm
launching the competition to find our
best local restaurants
begin week out the best local
independent restaurants across Britain
serve great food with passion and pride
I believe it's time for us to celebrate
these unsung heroes because I think they
deserve our support now more than ever
this year I asked you where you love to
eat your response was incredible there's
a wealth of fabulous food in Britain and
nearly 10 000 of you nominated your
favorite local restaurants
my team Journal some foodie Janet Street
Porter
and the f words maitre d John Baptiste
we checked out the places you love to
eat
all three of us are searching across the
country high and low to put these
restaurants under scrutiny we've had 10
000 nominations but there can only be
one winner who will be crowned the F
word's best local restaurants
tonight our competition continues with
one of the nation's favorites Indian
Curry corner from Cheltenham and lassan
in Birmingham will be battling out in
the f word kitchen serving samosas
monkfish and saffron cream Curry versus
sea bass in a Bengali fresh broth
and poached pears with mint and cardamom
custard
plus I'm off to Scotland on the ultimate
Indian stag do safety off venison Masala
is on the menu
in the recipe challenge Lenny Henry
demands some unusual ingredients put
your willy on this block and let's make
toast I'm Janet's mixed grill continues
to grow
oh God it's like a pubic hair
[Music]
all right
kitchen how are you feeling how are you
it's managing it's fine what's the
secret about tonight's service what are
you going to do differently we're going
to do everything perfectly everything
perfectly yes sure glad to hear it actor
how are you I'm very excited
um just want to serve my customers now I
need one of you can walk out here this
evening as a winner yes yeah you're here
because you're the best you've got to
prove it now
Curry corner from Cheltenham and lassan
from Birmingham are our top two Indian
contenders here's how I found them
We're a nation of Curry fans it's one of
Britain's favorite dishes and you the f
word viewers nominated hundreds of
Indian restaurants
but we could only choose two to compete
in the f word kitchen the search took us
all over Britain
determined to find the very best we went
to visit your culinary Heroes
from Nottingham to Portsmouth London to
Tamworth Southampton to Leeds all of
these things got very definite flavors
[Music]
flavors but sometimes the surroundings
weren't quite so impressive I hope it
feels good because the Decker was
shocking I feel like I'm in pink
doctor's bathroom
this is proper authentic Indian food
served inside a cafe with Cafe prices
the food is delicious it looks like this
menu has been has been here has been
sitting here for ages it's absolutely
disgusting
[Music]
after months of whittling down the
nominations we finally found two
outstanding restaurants
Kerry corner and Cheltenham give us a
fantastically warm welcome
nestling in the heart of the Cotswolds
this is one of the oldest Bangladeshi
restaurants in Britain
how are you
good to see you fair One D thank you
what lovely Place head chef samshell
creary is still going strong at 59
helped in the kitchen by his wife salaha
and daughter marusha
oh my God look at the size of the
kitchen as small as my nudes so you're
not the head chef hi I think
I think you need a head chef my head
would be off so I wouldn't even bother
sure
you see everything nice
talk about a proper family run friendly
business incredible in the kitchen with
your wife your daughter and your son in
front of the house
he's been cooking for 42 years
as far as [__] Bulldog every single
person in this family loves food Cooks
it eats it thinks about it every single
moment first up for me samosas
extraordinary Foods did you have to
travel to Bangladesh to get that kind of
flavor
and he's Managed IT
the lampshade just slides down the bar
and I mean it's cooked perfectly I
haven't even tasted it yet but you can
just tell
[Music]
it would be an absolute dream come true
to win the Air Force first local
restaurant it would mean the world to us
I'm happy we're going to win
thank you for that
um my problem is that this is a tough
category because there are amazing
Indian restaurants across the country
sadly the bad news is there's only two
restaurants that can go through
to the f word restaurants
congratulations you're one of them
next time it's gonna be the airport
Russian for 50 diners and trust me
they're tough cookies congratulations
I'll see you in London definitely the
right decision without a shadow of doubt
this place is unique it's refined
they've managed to focus on Flavor
Gordon's expecting great things from us
so we just hope we can deliver oh yes
okay
so Curry corner from Cheltenham is
through and in a group with such high
standards we've found a brilliant and
worthy opponent lasan in Birmingham good
to see you good to see you stunningly
stylish lassan is a city center favorite
head chef akhtar Islam was just 22 years
old when he opened the restaurant with
his best friend Jabba
the young gun from the Midlands are
determined to be different with
cutting-edge cuisine
for Birmingham we were the Pioneers we
were the first restaurant to break away
from the mainstream and I'll offer
alternatives to your baltis and your
Tikka masalas that's exquisitely
presented finesse
very competitive you know we set out to
be number one and hopefully one day
we'll make it home baby chicken thank
you well with fried Ginger
hmm
what's the ambition the Sun what is it
it's not food for uh people who haven't
got an educated palette it is a very
sophisticated Cuisine I haven't come
across any Indian food anywhere yet with
fried leeks sun-dried tomatoes fried
gingers that's dried in the oven I mean
it's just everything that goes into the
actual food itself yeah
that is as authentic we just ultimately
we're trying to bring the food forward a
bit so you're looking for a mission star
or are you looking for I'm hoping to get
mentioned today yeah that's the plan I
love his arrogance because he reminds me
very similar to myself you know 15 years
ago the biggest problem that you have
today is that you're trying too hard the
arrogance versus the confidence you've
got a little bit of me in there
and you know there's only two
restaurants that can go through and cook
in the f word
[Music]
and you're one of them congratulations
sure well done very much just I do want
to kiss you yeah we've done it
I mean it's amazing it is probably the
the biggest thing that has ever happened
to any of us I definitely think I've
made the right decision one hell of a
cocky Chef young but bloody talented
thank you so I found my top two Indian
restaurants well the f word diners
prefer Curry Corners traditional charm
or lassan's ambitious modern take on
Indian food who will be crowned the F
word's best local Indian restaurant
we're about to find out
teams are going to cook 25 portions of
the starters and make sure those
customers pay for your food excited yeah
sure yeah okay let's go onto stations
let's get ready for starters yeah let's
go
next on the menu I'm Up Before Dawn on a
mission to bagadir for my venison Masala
are we ready I was born ready
and in the recipe challenge a jealous
Lenny Henry squares up for a fight he
had a snug with my wife
we're back in London at the f word
restaurants and tonight it's Indian
night
the value of the Indian food market in
Britain is around 500 million pounds but
who does it best we searched the country
and found the Edwards top two local
Indian restaurants in Birmingham and
Curry Corner in Cheltenham okay guys
first couple of tables coming in right
listen let's
able one four lamb samosas yes chef yes
you'd have to shop for theirs but thank
you anyway right Kerry Corner listen up
please
yes sir yes chef tonight both brigades
are kicking off with samosas here's my
recipe for this delicious Indian starter
chickpea samosas delicious simple and so
straightforward first to filling
vegetable oil not too hot in order to
burn those spices curry powder garam
masala cumin turmeric
[Music]
fry onion
in to the spices seasoned cream chili
just wakes everything up
garlic ginger
next add chickpeas and peas water nice
simmer
lemon juice
lightly Crush cool
Samosa dough roll cut out
take the disc and just cut it in half
form a little cone
fill water
[Music]
seal knit together nice and gently
hot pan
vegetable oil fry
salad
out
chickpea samosas with salad right a
dressing
done
guys this is not a race okay it's a
restaurant Hector yes yeah give me a
time on the first floor please yes
good man excellent both rations are
cooking their own Samosa recipes it'll
be interesting to see who comes out on
top
foreign
Birmingham Pride themselves on taking
authentic Indian cooking in an exciting
and modern Direction it's an old
and we are the new generation
for their lamb Samosa they marinate the
meat in raw papaya paste for 24 hours to
make sure it's exquisitely tender
and they're using a special kind of thin
biscuity pastry called nimki adding
Nigella seeds for an aromatic flavor
actor The Filling inside the Samosa is
lamb and that's spiced with the usual
you know you've got chili turmeric
braised it is braised but then what we
do we totally evaporate all the sauce
then we just pound it mix it with some
mint and coriander and it's just uh put
into the pastry
food yeah I hope the diners like this
one those first four actor
now you're using a cutter for yours yeah
yes okay what's the secret behind that
the secret behind it is it'll just seal
the pastry off yeah and also this is how
it's made at home
[Music]
family run Curry Corner in Cheltenham
have been serving their traditional home
style Indian food for 32 years
we've got probably a hundred years worth
of um cooking experience between all of
us our family is all about food and I
don't think you can beat that
for their Samosa filling Curry Corner
cooked the Lamb with roast spices
cinnamon cardamom Baileys and cloves
for their dough they're using a light
whole wheat flour that can be rolled out
into a much thinner pastry
is actually my grandmother's recipe so
it's a lot more home style
in your any of my cooking I mean any of
my cookies yes
I love my mom's stuff yeah they look
fantastic are we now five more please
yes hello beautiful well done
hi Tom so you're quite a modern young
cookers turn up to the restaurant
expecting a chicken tikka masala and a
beer it does it does annoy me it's not
something that you know an experience I
have to endure very often Indian food
can offer so much more so why take up
menu space with the tikka masala right
simple as in my kitchens I'll never
serve that you'll never serve a chicken
chicken masala never serve a chicken
chicken masala if you try my muscle live
Challenge and nobody makes in the UK you
have the best I am sorry any chef you
challenge actor any any chef yes any
chef how long we've been cooking show 40
41 years 41 years how old are you Hector
I'm 29 Chef when was the last time you
ate a chicken chicken masala
um
about 12 years ago how was it uh
horrible so uh I didn't like the amount
of food coloring in there I thought it
was totally unnatural in color if you
want Samsung to email the recipe for you
uh more than welcome but it wouldn't
find its way into my menu I don't use
any color what color is it natural
natural color
like a lovely orangey color from all the
caramelization of the Browning of the
onions and all the rest of the Masala
you freshly grind the spices down in
release flavors and it'll color up the
curry naturally all right but um if you
said it was red then I'd I'd probably
say um
that's well done but what I would say I
mean when you mentioned the tikka masala
sauce
they don't even have that practice of
cooking in Bangladesh
oh Jesus
[Applause]
let's agree to disagree is an Indian
snob yes okay yeah I need two tails of
four from you yeah yeah
oh my gosh now everybody loves the curry
but as actor would tell us there's so
much more to Indian cookery than a
chicken tikka masala
over 6 000 Indian restaurants in the UK
serve 3 million happy customers a week
but the vast majority of the dishes they
offer are either chicken or lamb
all delicious but I believe with such a
limited range of meat we're missing out
on a world of culinary opportunity
to prove this I'm going to recreate a
true Indian classic using a piece of
meat that you won't find on your average
Indian menu anywhere venison
it's a wonderfully Rich gaming
ingredient that's a perfect match for
highly spiced flavors
I've come to Scotland in search of the
finest wild deer for my delicious new
dish one that deserves a place on any
Indian menu venison masala
I'm hunting with moberak Jam who
regularly stalks deer up here
most Indian restaurants use halal meat
and I'm Keen to know how Wild venison
can be halau
Mo's a Muslim Hunter and he's going to
show me how he does it what was it
attracted to you why why do you want to
start shooting well it's mainly really
sort of um the sort of hunter-gatherer
kind of thing you know shooting for your
own food taking it home taking some
venison home and cooking it up and
having beautiful food
joining us is Jim mccurlin who's going
to help us track down a deer if you spot
one and I haven't seen it just cool
and that's all I'll hear it yeah don't
Point don't raise any hands
are we ready let's go I was born ready
but there are elusive creatures and
Incredibly difficult to shoot and what
could spooking noise scent
after two hours Jim spots her first deer
see those tall trees up there he's just
out he's just coming
here he comes he's running along the
bottom [__]
ing stop left see him oh yeah yeah
just as I'm getting ready to take the
shot
[Music]
I lose it
that they're gonna be coming back now a
little bastard Beyond back
[Music]
next day we set off again but the deer
always seemed to be one step ahead of us
several hours of hard slog Jim spotted a
Road Deer
oh stay there
I can't see him
Gordon
safety off no
foreign
I follow up with a second shot
he's dead yeah quite a strange feeling
to bring with isn't it yes
but when you've got it in your sights
like that your heart's just beating
absolutely beating yeah big deep breath
they call it back fever then it's time
for Mo to show me how he makes sure his
deer is halal
as well as saying a prayer when he pulls
the trigger he slits the throat in a
special way what I would do yeah to make
it Halal yeah you used to repeat the
prayer Bismillah
that's it that's it one swift back and
forth that's the main thing with Halal
the knife has to be razor sharp we do it
this way to get all the blood out the
carcass
um just so it's nice and clean well done
Gordon
the Moment of Truth time for me to cook
my venison Masala for Mo and Jim
I'm gonna be using venison the most shot
of the weekend it's been hung and
chilled and more importantly he shot it
so therefore it's Halal the first thing
we'll do is make the most amazing dry
rub
mix cumin fennel seeds chili powder
coriander seeds and chili flakes
that down
rub the spices into the meat into the
pan
it's nice
cook for about four minutes basting
continuously then remove from the Heat
and as it starts to cool down in the oil
it takes on all that wonderful flavor
from the spices for the Masala sauce
grate one onion
season and add garam masala turmeric
garlic and ginger we can afford to make
it a little bit more spicy because it's
going up against a dense Rich venison
chilies chopped tomatoes and a splash of
water great to hold cauliflower and add
to the mix Masala paste starts to absorb
it finely add chopped coriander and a
squeeze of lemon
and there you go and that's not worth
six hours pissing around the bushes I
don't know what it is
I'm really Keen to find out if Moe likes
my venison Masala you like that that's
good that's what I want to see that
smile on your face that's good stuff
what do you think of venison everyone
thinks it's associated with Posh dinners
but I've always thought it goes quite
well with the Indian spices quite dense
quite gamey yeah why don't they use it
across Indian Cuisine to be honest I
don't think it's available it's readily
available there's all the like lamb and
chicken and stuff there's a new business
for you yeah
the last table of force I'm sure yeah
yeah last table actor you've got one
table two
last two yeah goes down like exact same
as the first two yeah
yes last table good all right well done
sure yes well done
I really enjoyed the start time all the
flavors work together the meat was
really really tender the coating
it's a nice bounce dish really flavors
them actually it was really really
impressed and now how do you think he's
doing tonight is
and the filling unfortunately wasn't
flavorsome or
um
other spices oh my God they're getting a
kicking from you remember oh my God more
important are you gonna pay for it no
I'm afraid no uh enjoy your main courses
I started was great actually it was
really soft and succulent inside the
spices all complemented each other
really well the lamb was just cooked
really well crispy pastry it was to die
for really really good now nice to see
you how are you welcome to f word it's
beautiful
now how do you think Central's doing how
do you think he's pairing up on the
pressure it's very well very very good
are you a proud wife of course of course
I'm a proud do you want to jump in there
again and give them a hand no no he's
all right he can cook it now what do you
think of lassan's um the feeling is okay
but the pastry is too thin for me and I
feel it too oily for me and the most
important question are you gonna be
paying for it tonight no no no well how
was it yeah it was the semester itself
was to be honest yes all right the lamb
was very nice very well cooked come on
yes or no are you paying for it yeah I
think you're gonna pay for it good to
see you excellent
so code Corner first
nice and crispy
pastry is fantastic
the Samosa filling I want to be a little
bit more spicy it's a shame because you
start cutting through the pastry and
it's like wow crispy
delicious blistered all over and then
you get to the
Center and it's not as exciting as the
outside now tactiles inside peas braised
lamb
wow that's delicious it doesn't actually
look like a classic Samosa however the
flavor is extraordinary
of course yes how well do you think you
did our 25 Samsung how many customers
are done very good actor how old do you
think you did 25 out of 25 25 I love
your confidence okay right JB let's go
here we go okay Curry Corner first the
number of customers yeah out of 25 that
are happy to pay for your Samosa is
wow
18 out of 25 well done thank you really
well done
pretty good 18.
really good
um feedback please yeah
okay right less hands the number
of customers out of 25 they're willing
to pay for your samosas is
24 out of 25 well done
really well done really
good news really good news
here we go 18 out of 25 yes and 24 out
of 25 yeah two very good results good
play down get ready for main course
let's go well done
[Music]
[Applause]
next on the menu Janet's mission to
raise all the meat for my competition
final continues and when it comes to
chipolatas Size Matters I mean what sex
is it I can't tell Christine I don't
know what I'm looking for
oh boy how'd you know it's a boy because
it's got money
Lenny Henry shows me his Marco Pierre
White impression
Curry corner be able to come back and
teach lasan a lesson
you can't let this boy beat you come on
now both Russians are gonna put their
main courses therefore diners first up
lassan
[Music]
fried filter Bass with the Bengali fish
broth please lassan's Village of sea
bass in Bengali fish broth is a modern
Indian dish derived from a traditional
recipe
first actor hates mustard oil adds
mustard seeds just a generous pinch and
we're gonna wait for that to start
popping Curry leaves onions and garlic
and allows to sweat
he then adds two whole chilies snapping
them at the ends the seeds stay inside
what we're trying to do is get
[Music]
guitar adds turmeric coriander and chili
powder a little bit more than the
coriander three times as much as the
turmeric next fish heads full of intense
flavor akhtar is using Roy Bengali carp
which adds to the authenticity of this
dish
then he adds Tomatoes coriander water
and simmers
after an hour the broth is strained he
cooks potatoes in the broth and adds
lime juice
the sea bass fillets are seasoned with
turmeric chili then coated in rice flour
it's going to help us get skin very
crispy they're fried skin side down and
turned
[Music]
pan-fried fillets of sea bass in Bengali
fish broth
served
broth major flavors are coming through
on that is the coriander garlic and
tomato with a hint of chili or a bit of
a kick that's very nice lovely
for my Chef's or Chef I know if you
don't get 15 out of 50 pay for your main
course you're gonna be gutting tonight
come on
you can't let this boy beat you come on
this is what Curry Corner have on
tonight's menu
Curry Corner signature dish is monkfish
and saffron cream Curry
first Shams will fries some fresh garlic
and ginger he then adds salt cardamom
pods cloves bay leaves and stirs in a
whole crushed cinnamon stick
Shams will add onions and red peppers
with tomato puree cumin turmeric
coriander and chili powder
measuring by eye with these 40 years of
experience
then he lets the flavors really Infuse
large fish shamsal then coats the
monkfish with pepper
mustard seeds fennel seeds and ajwan an
Asian spice that tastes a lot like thyme
he then fries the fish
to finish the sauce Cham saw Heats a
spoonful of his spice mix in a pan and
adds cream
then milk with saffron and lime leaves a
chopped spring onion
buy tomato and fresh coriander
finally he adds his monkfish coconut
milk and shreddy coconut
it's complete
monkfish and saffron cream Curry
served
what makes that dish stand out the very
very subtle flavoring from the spices
but it's a very delicate flavor aggar's
broth has a strong pungent kick to it
yours is very delicate it's very
delicate because the fish is very
delicate right and all we need is
something to just lift the sweetness of
the fish which is the most important
part each dish is looking like the first
let's go well done yeah
service please let's go right now it's
time to check on Janet Street farmer
oh [__] I'm challenging Janice Street
Porter to raise all the meat for the
competition final at the f word
restaurant last week she started a farm
with seven miniature Dexter cattle look
I'm in charge now
this week I'm adding to Janet's
challenge with the rarest breed of pork
we've ever had in the f word kitchen
the bully mangalitza
to help her choose three piglets I've
sent her to meet an old friend pig
expert Christine Koh I've forgotten my
Wellies I hope you're going to be very
wet
is that a pig that is a pig looks like
she's wearing a wig sure this pig hasn't
got two pile no look give her a stroke
do I have to she's got fleas
mangalitas were first bred in Hungary in
the early 19th century
closer related to Wild Boar and with a
nervous temperament to match mangalits
has produced beautiful meat with a
stronger gamier flavor and as the
fattiest pig in the world they're
perfect for salami cured loin and bacon
not like any pubic hair I've seen anyway
enough about the sow it's time for Janet
to meet her piglets this is just over a
couple of weeks ago
right doesn't it
they're so tiny when they're born
absolutely but they're straight there
into the tea
intelligent they are they they always
sift the mum's bottom because that's how
they recognize them oh no
well I know they're going to be tasty
because I've just eaten a sausage made
from one of their ancestors
[Music]
[Applause]
so they're ready to go to their new mum
and Janet's three now not so little pigs
are arriving in Yorkshire
before they can go into the brand new
pen Jenna needs to give him a quick
health check can I wear these yeah I'm
not gonna wear them because I need to be
able to feel you're at one with pigs I'm
on a learning curve
now we have to try and stay very relaxed
around them right look at its eyes nice
clear eyes they're not runny they're not
runny no it's not runny not very runny
no you're fine Trotters Trotters look
perfect what dinky little Trotters
you've got can you just have a look at
the bottom to see if he's got the runs
ugh how do I know just look and poke
about a bit I'm not nothing but I'm not
waiting for him to have to runs and what
sex is it what we got underneath well
there's alarm what does that mean have
we got anything in the back I can't tell
Christine I don't know what I'm looking
for it's a boy how do you know it's a
boy because it's got money probably a
lot of lump that'll do I'll Stand still
for God's sake 11 kilos right meet your
mate so that they're ready for the f
word restaurant and he'd each picked a
game from one and a half to two kilos in
weight each week the equivalent of two
bags of sugar
this one's much heavier but you're
leaning on it
it's really important to do these checks
particularly after they've had a little
bit straight and a long journey just to
make sure they're starting off healthy
you are now the pride owner of three of
the rarest pigs in the UK
they look fantastic look mate The
Neighbors
Janet's chosen her pigs and cows and all
she needs now to complete her mixed
grill is some chickens her challenge is
about to get even harder
Dennis
yeah how are they they're fantastic
they're so Lively but I picked a special
breed of big manga licks do you like
them yeah I like their hair oh really
blonde right pubic also the Grecian 2000
grayish it's like your hair curly all
right okay I think that's why you picked
them isn't it so you're saying I've got
things on top of my head you had trouble
finding their penises as well that is
the kind of thing you're obsessed with
it
through life I've never seen that
upstairs with searching the venuses I
don't know where they are so it's not
worth finding it's not worth having no
pretty good to see you please look after
my animals safe trip back to the farm
every time I comb their hair yes I'll be
thinking of you
yeah come on guys you're the best
freshman to prove it yes yes tomorrow
night none of you'll get another chance
to do this again so really make it count
the sea bass was kind of variety to
Perfection it was really lovely in the
broth but it was absolutely perfect the
sea bass was quite Lively I think it was
quite a modern tick on Indian Cuisine
everything together just complemented
each other it was beautiful and I would
definitely pay for us the sea bass I
like very much but this is the dish I I
find is too hot for me
oh the monkfish is amazing the flavors
really worked and and it wasn't too rich
it was really beautiful the monkfish it
was quite tough and I just think that
the spices there was no kick to it no
kick to the dish
right so lesson sea bass looks amazing
in terms of presentation
yeah it's bold but it's incredibly
delicious that broth is very very rich
and that wakes up the sea bass very good
Curry Corners monkfish looks more
traditional
it's very delicate and I like it but
it's not spicy enough that needs to be a
little bit more aggressive in terms of
flavor the sea bass for me the broth
seals it
all right let's find out how he did
out of 50. take an educated guess
what we see it
35 35 or 50. actor how well do you think
that sea bass went down I'm hoping will
will be in the high 40s fingers crossed
okay let's do you first yeah the number
of customers that are happy to pay for
your sea bass out of 50 is
40 out of 50. well done really well done
that's good really well done
40 out of 50. it's good
so JB uh 10 customers didn't play for
CVS why yeah uh too spicy but 40 out of
50. that's bloody good right Curry
Corner the number yeah of customers
willing to pay for your monkfish out of
50.
is
27 out of 50. wow 27.
damn that's tough that's 23 customer's
out of 50. you're not happy to pay why
not
um to blend and the fish to Ribery as
well and the fish being too rubbery yeah
okay don't be disappointed no no
we can pull this back on desserts yes
you've got to get 25 out of 25 a dessert
yes you're both talented enough to do it
yeah clear down let's go yeah well done
you never know they've made they might
be able to turn it around I'm still
optimistic that they will they will win
is one of Britain's most loved comedians
is he's cooking as good as he jokes I'm
about to find out are you ready yes very
excited I'm very happy to be here I'm
going to cook some Jamaican food I need
dumpling I need pumpkin I need yam yes
chef now what are you cooking I'm
cooking Pepper Pot soup my mom used to
cook it and it's just something that
Jamaicans have she used to serve it in a
terrine for each member of the family
it's why our family's so big we just go
come on now the food ready get the spoon
what are you making over there I'm gonna
do my childhood favorite soup Scotch
broth oh Scotch broth using mutton and
barley barley yeah I don't know if
you've got food like this but it's one
of those things where you miss it and so
you know my mom passed away in 1998. so
when I eat it anywhere like there's a
place in London called um Savannah jerk
yep which is a very good Jamaican
restaurant but I love going to yeah and
they they gave it to me the other day
and uh I I sort of burst into tears
really yeah because that memorable well
it's one of those evocative meals you
so how did Dawn and your mum get on
really well do you bondage straight away
oh yeah first time John came to my house
right my mom used to do this it was like
a cooking test with every new girlfriend
you know my mom used to bring this plate
of food out like this that was like
eight feet high
and it was chicken and rice and dumpling
green banana and yam and sweet potatoes
and literally Dawn's head was like that
over the top like that
yourself darling and so um and what you
got to do is you've got to you've got to
show that you've got some heart and eat
it you know and she did eat it I was
very proud of her clearly she passed a
test yeah she passed the test how is
your Namby Bambi Scotch brush with
barley going this is my mother's recipe
so Scotch Roth like Lenny I'm gonna be
using a mutton partly cooking the mutton
in a light stock for 20 minutes so it
gets really nice and tender the
important part bring up the ball and
skim the top vegetables celery carrots
sweet turnips and then barley okay what
I've done is I've put the meat and the
kidney beans into uh boil it says boil
typical Jamaican well the meat and the
arm the beans for 20 minutes non-stop
until them done and then put in the
vegetables and let them simmer so I'm
doing the meat bit first we've had some
fantastic reviews from fellow there's a
fellow a carrot that you can relate to I
can relate to them a lot actually
because he's the only black guy in the
village
it's one of the first schools I went to
I was one of three black kids in the
entire school if anything got stolen
they'd just go black kid black kid won
get over here did you do this as you
know Dawn was a guest which I had the
most amazing snock
[Music]
you had a snug with my wife it was just
uh you know you don't mind do you yes I
do mind put your willy on this block and
let's make toast she left something is
she did you give it to her when you say
next please
I've got you
are there any times okay good joke
are there any times across the show live
that you forget your lines it's a live
performance you know there are going to
be times when your concentration might
slip for a brief second do you ever get
tempted to throw in a little joke like a
okay something
I grew up in Japanese
my friends you can't do that I was very
tempted the other night I started saying
something three times the tyrant
the tyrant
the tyrant and I was so tempted to go
Chaka Khan the tyrant
so the mutton's been cooking now for 25
minutes it's now nice and soft all that
fat has been removed adding that into
the vegetables and then topping that up
with the stock Barley's in so it's just
started open up and this is the stock
that the mutton's been cooked in bring
up to the boil crack the seasoning turn
it down and let it simmer I'm trying to
make the dumplings now I've also got
Scotch bonnet pepper in my eyes
um I've had to take one of my contact
lenses out because I'm clearly dying
right now both suits have to cook for 20
minutes and the blind tasters will pick
a winner
and I can already smell victory
something burning over there God damn
next on the menu Curry Corner have to
pull out all the stops if they're going
to win the title of the F word's best
local Indian restaurant and have a
chance of a place in the final
we are behind at the moment but we think
we can pull it back
and Lenny Henry suggests a new career
for the f words maitre d
you took an audition for a boy band or
something
right welcome back to the airport now
time for the results of the recipe
challenge first we've got a plate up
ready
yours smells delicious good right JB yes
off you go good luck thank you JB are
you doing an audition for a boy band or
something look at you guys
mmm spicy
it's quite thick though yeah it is the
lamp could be a bit more tender it's
quite nice actually it's just a bit
spicy a little bit doughy that is really
nice
fresh herbs deeper flavor
gives a lovely texture
all right good luck Good Luck Good Luck
uh oh no he's got that look about him
okay let's go how do they go down first
in yours they love the valley was very
like homie style
um very nice yeah yeah he stole it from
his mother yeah right
the score is 41.
four to one the winner is
yeah I like yours it was nice
perfect our last Paul Lenny I beat him
well well of course you'd be
the swing star Chef I'm like a comedian
Shakespeare out of my kitchen
yes
ah how could best I was here that's bad
isn't it look how happy he is come on
right now it's time for dessert
it's fantastic to spice up desserts this
is a delicious saffron poached pear with
a cardamom custard first peel your pears
half
core add 150 grams of caster sugar to
boiling water then a pinch of saffron
poach the pears for 20 minutes
mint and cardamom custard add 300
milliliters of milk to a saucepan
four crushed cardamom pods
slowly bring to the boil
sieve
three egg yolks
50 grams of sugar
add the cardamom fused milk
and return to the Heat
stir constantly and allow to thicken
mint
drain the pears
caster sugar
glaze
that smells delicious
saffron poached pear with mint and
cardamom custard done
once you've added the sugar into this
you've got to whisk it okay if you leave
it okay it goes grainy there you go
whisk this whisk they're good
don't slicing too thin otherwise I'll
break yeah good that's it yeah sure yes
I filmed your day lady earlier your wife
yeah very proud of you tonight you know
that I'm marusha too but she doesn't
think acto's a man for you by the way
there'll be a lot of mothers who think
that
good good service please very nice very
nice that comes to look fantastic okay
well done good
it must be hard for you walking around
Cheltenham Playhouse for autographs
thinking that you're George Clooney
do they yeah no all the time that's all
the time easy okay how are we doing
that's it okay yes [__] are you ready to
go good lovely good thanks I
was marvelous I love the contrast of
savory and sweet it was absolutely
beautiful the crispy mint was just
perfected it just Blended everything
together perfectly thoroughly enjoyable
really enjoyed it I finished you very
light very nice it was light it was
fragrant and generally I really enjoyed
it and I might have finished my sisters
okay first off end of the night well
done I think all four of you done
brilliantly well and you are a true
legend yes thank you well done really
well done okay ready for the results JB
please
okay thank you Curry Corner let's start
with you first yes the number of
customers that are happy to pay out of
25 for their dessert is
19 out of 25. well done really fantastic
huh that's great news
that means in total you have got 6 4 out
of 100. hold on
[Applause]
quick moment the number I've ever diners
yes that are happy to pay out of 25 yeah
for your poached pairs is
12 out of 25
but there is good news because you have
a total of 76 out of 100.
well done
all done great stuff
really well done one of my darling
congratulations
now all of you do me a big favor and get
out of here and get yourself a lassie
well done really well done excellent
sensation is absolutely amazing I mean
you know we've made it so far and to
have won as well I mean I'm just shaking
inside on it it's just
so lasan are in first place on the f
word leaderboard but can they hold on to
the top spot and go through to the next
round
next week we'll be crowning the F word's
best local French restaurant does your
local have that special
that's how they serve food at the Ritz
I'll be in Paris learning about pastry
and teaching the French a thing or two
while I'm there so you're cursing a
boobie
hello what is it will be
as the final ingredient for a mixed
grill arrives
let's see it
welcome to the f word I'm searching the
country to find our best local
restaurants
Britain's independent restaurants serve
fantastic food in the heart of our
communities and each week I'm choosing
two unsung country heroes to compete in
the f word kitchen
guys may this count yes there's only
four points different in this so far
salvos from Leeds has been crowned the F
word's best local Italian restaurant
snatched Victory from their French
Rivals
from Birmingham were delighted with the
Indian trophy
just shaking inside them is just and
Chinese Sweet Mandarin from Manchester
swept to the top of the leaderboard to
Manchester
tonight is all about Thai a Cuisine
that's become incredibly popular in the
UK
be tied for Middlesex take on yum yum
from North London to fight for the Thai
trophy
Scary Spice is in the f word kitchen
cold yeah I'm going now
in the recipe challenge let's hope Rory
bremner's trifle is better than his
impression of me we've got everything
here restaurants yes cameraman yes chef
yes celebrities yes ingredients yes
let's [__] do I cook for some very
special diners
how is it
but will I make the grade this is not
Pad Thai at all this is not Panama
see hello
[Applause]
great to have you guys here in my
kitchen now the secret success behind
Simply Thai is what heart and soul love
and care now yum yum yep yum yum who
came up with that name me you yes good
good you are my two Top Thai restaurants
make this the best service of your
entire life yes chef
tonight simply tie from Teddington and
yum yum from North London are competing
in the f word kitchen this is how they
got here
earlier this year I asked you to log on
to the f word website and nominate your
favorite local restaurants
the response has been absolutely
phenomenal
you told us about nearly 5 000 different
places you love to eat 40 years ago
there was only one Thai restaurant in
Britain now there's one in nearly every
town We're a nation of Thai food
fanatics
with the help of my team I set out to
whittle down your nominations
so you really write the phone all right
great we were looking for the very best
you just give you a very warm nice
comfortable feeling that you are in a
proper Thai restaurant we're traveling
across the country really putting these
nominated restaurants under severe
scrutiny we went to the Thai restaurants
you really care about and after months
of searching it was clear that two of
your Thai favorites were exceptional
first up Simply Thai in Teddington
with just 10 tables it's a tiny
restaurant run by a tiny chef but Patria
wear a pan has a hugely passionate
temperament
I just got a normal Chef temperament I
possibly like Gordon in the kitchen
um firing tempered
Patria Works ferociously hard seven days
a week sleeping just five hours a night
play it now
she makes every dish almost
single-handedly and each one has to be
absolutely Flawless White
[Music]
plate if you are a perfectionist you're
not gonna let anything go with even tiny
tiny fold
Trey has dedicated her life to creating
perfect Thai Cuisine she left her family
in Bangkok 37 years ago and she's never
married or had children
My Time is Here in the restaurant the
me is my my home is my family I was
fascinated to finally meet this colorly
firecracker hello
how are you good afternoon
Simply Thai the secret success is what I
cooked a very good food yes traditional
Thai food and I cook with my love my
care my passion everything my heart I
put into every single dishes
amazing absolutely amazing 57 years of
age on our own and Cooks every day sleep
five hours a night if that's not passion
I don't know what it is
open plan kitchen sees the dining room
obviously the kitchen and everything's
just about food food
first up for me King prawn special
and I also had to try Patrice crispy sea
bass with jungle Curry
as I scare me honestly I feel like I've
met a female Gordon Ramsay from Bangkok
it's incredibly crispy I mean really
crispy
amazing hot spicy and everything won
from Thai food this lady chews from the
hip it's not a traditional Thai
restaurant this lady's pushing the
boundaries out it's not a selection of
curries I mean the menu is authentic but
she homes in on the ingredients that's
the exciting thing I won the best and I
give the best
32 seats
yeah
is one thing
what I need you to do is to start
cooking for 50 because you're through
congratulations okay I need you to work
at cooking for 50 not 32. okay
congratulations well done
really well done that food was delicious
really delicious and if you cook that
crispy sea bass with your jungle green
curry amazing really good
Simply Thai no that's the compass Thai
cooking
um yeah I mean a real Thoroughbred I
mean my God that woman's passionate she
sacrificed her life for that Russian
come true I wouldn't even want to win a
jackpot I wouldn't be excited is that
because he's my achievement my hard work
if you've got strong determination you
would achieve what you want so simply
time is through and from your
nominations we found an opponent who
couldn't be more different
yum yum is on the High Street in Stoke
Newington North London I knew the f word
viewers loved it
yum yum is run by antique and Moy
Chowdhury
this dedicated couple have worked for 17
years to build one of Britain's biggest
Thai restaurants
in contrast to Simply ties 10 tables yum
yum has nearly 90.
about myself
Moy is the head chef this is the
lemongrass one stem of it when yum yum
opened she only had two people in the
kitchen now she has an army of Staff 14
waiters and 16 chefs catering for up to
500 customers every night always full of
people
great atmosphere customers say it's
brilliant as usual as all the time so
that made me very proud
Moy is a talented cook who's also built
up an amazing business I can't wait to
taste her Thai Cuisine
let's see Gordon good to see you look
the size of this
is huge hello
where's Moy
what's your signature dish what is it
your lamb Curry who's the boss
everything in here good I like to hear
that
everybody yes right I'll go upstairs get
out of your way
first up for me Yum Yum's most popular
starter the fish cakes
the presentation is beautiful
[Music]
we eat with our eyes before taking
ingredient
it's just my passion so that's why our
restaurant pack every night for my main
course lamb and peanut butter curry
Lamb's just falling off the bone lovely
so you've got the effect of the bone
marrow
flavor it's 10 times greater and it's
cooked so slow when that lamb dish
arrived with those potatoes and the lamb
cooked on the bone yeah it was
definitely there without a doubt proper
authentic Thai cooking the competition
you made me very proud this country has
been in love with Thai food for many
years
um I'm really sorry you're gonna have to
take a night off next week
congratulations because you are through
okay congratulations well done thank you
forget big numbers nothing to do it just
comb in on 50 stunning portions of your
main course just cook from the heart
that's it that's it they're important
like very important
[Music]
I feel very very excited and then I'll
do my best on that day
Moy I mean she's amazing I mean there's
a level of passion there from her and
you can you can taste it through the
food
from your nominations I've chosen two
extraordinary Thai restaurants
all the f word diners prefer Patrice
obsessive attention to detail
or will it be seduced by the
sophistication of Mighty yum yum
who will be crowned the f words queen of
Thai Cuisine
on the menu as the Thai teams go head to
head in the kitchen have I finally met
my match
what did you just said she's angry watch
out don't make her angry otherwise we're
all screwed I'm cooking Thai food for
Buddhist monks brings me to my knees
[Music]
foreign
we're back in London at the f word
restaurants
tonight akuzina has exploded in
popularity in the UK Thai
with its irresistible combination of
fresh flavors Exquisite presentation and
healthy ingredients it's no wonder that
Thai food has become a hit with the
nation's food lovers and thanks for your
nominations and months of searching we
found the F word's best to local Thai
restaurants yum yum in North London and
Simply Thai in Teddington
[Music]
25 portions of each is not a race right
on all the four covers table one yum yum
two prawn fish cakes
Simply Thai six cod fish cake
yes chef thank you though you scared me
then
hidden away in the London suburb of
Teddington there's a Thai restaurant so
authentic it wouldn't be out of place in
amongst the back streets of Bangkok
the Russian success is a testament to
the die-hard dedication of 57 year old
kitchen Dynamo Patria I've always got
very high ambition I want to get the top
of everything I do simply time I only
have 10 tables but every single dish is
cooked or finished by Patria don't do
anything you understand
Safari temperament and obsessive quality
control are remarkable I never never
take a shortcut doesn't matter how busy
the restaurant if things go smoothly I
get bored for soup Thai's fish cakes
Petro uses only the finest freshest Cod
fillet the served with ajard a
traditional Thai cucumber salad
what's in here
what's in here um is cucumber
ly and this syrup it is sugar vinegar
and what does sweet and sour work so
well in Thai cooking what's the secret
behind that the Thai knows how to use
the sugar because English cooking don't
know how to use they don't you don't
have sugar in your in your roast beef
and Yorkie pudding definitely not no do
you think these are better than boys
yep where did this recipe come from uh
for my mom for me mom yeah
[Music]
17 years ready and how many photos of
the week do you sell we were five five
hundred pieces very popular amazing
has spent 17 years building up their
glamorous North London restaurant a
restaurant of this nature needs people
who appreciate the quality of what we
create
yum yum has had to open up a series of
new dining areas to make more room for
the ever-grown number of customers
I feel like I'm in Thailand it's the
most probably the easiest way I can
explain it yum yum has 36 staff and can
handle up to 500 covers a night the
success of this restaurant is built on
fantastic service and a delicious dining
experience which keeps their customers
coming back again and again they will
ask me are you expanding restaurant I
say no I want only one parent
using gray featherback a fish that's
highly prized in Thailand and will give
moy's dish a truly authentic Thai Flavor
would you ever cook these fish cakes in
a pan as opposed to being fine always
deep-fried always deep fry always you to
try in the oven right quite nice quite
nice but you dry so dry yes the last
table of two made these two as exciting
as the first two yeah
go go go Chef two seconds complete the
table first and I'll send them all just
in case yeah
yes
nice okay Table Six please let's go
my Simply Thai I've only got 30 covers
in the dining room so this should be
walking apart for you to beat Simply
Thai tonight yeah I'd be really share
myself
service please table 14. right some
people say that food is new religion
they may have a point
Britain is home to almost 30 000 Thai
people and in the heart of Southwest
London is Europe's only purpose-built
Thai temple where I'll be serving up a
very special meal I love Thai food I
love cooking it and I love eating it but
this has to be the most daunting task so
far
this small and revered group of Buddhist
monks live in the monastery attached to
the temple they spend most of their
waking hours meditating and studying
Buddha's teachings forbid them to cook
so is up to the local Thai Community to
offer the one meal the monks are allowed
to eat at 11 o'clock each day
helping me fulfill this honor and
privilege is Chang executive chef of the
blue elephant one of London's Top Thai
restaurants
morning
good morning everybody
yeah pressure's on right yeah so they've
got to be before 11 o'clock yeah are
they fussy eaters no they are really
nice they're really kind they ever send
food back no never
the restaurant prepares the very best
dishes to offer to the monastery and
every dish has to be perfect like these
Savory dumplings known as money bags so
that's the money bag and that's it yeah
sauce easy and simple maybe you can try
these dumplings are usually served as a
starter pork and crab meat are wrapped
in a delicate bean curd pastry and the
tops are tied with thin strips of spring
onion now the shoelace now is the next
step
nice and tight really tight and how'd
you call the money bag in your language
right money bags okay okay good Chang's
authentic money bags are delicious but I
want to show my take on a classic
Thailand's national dish Pad Thai okay a
quick Pad Thai I fry shallots garlic and
chili with salt and a little bit of
sugar color on the shallots
half the spring onions
this is a dish I love cooking at home
I'm using delicious King prawns and
adding some extras like chili and
Tamarind paste
I'm so excited
for the monks today yes never cooked for
months before you know those prawns
smell amazing
my pad thai is made sweet and sour with
fish sauce salt and sugar
turn up the gas
another Tamarind place
a beaten egg is cooked in the wok and
then added with the noodles and bean
sprouts to the sauce
I hope they're going to be happy with
this you know that I think that one will
be happy
prawns and fresh coriander finish the
pad thai but what will Chan think of my
quick and easy version of this classic
and then some peanuts around the outside
happy oh no they had a test yeah please
I have to taste it first
what do you want to know for me ask me
well how is it hmm oh no look at her
face this is not Pad Thai at all this is
not Panama no but I have to be sweet
sour and salty
I think that doesn't taste too bad
it's not perfect for you but not for me
you're a tough cookie I want to keep an
eye on the monks to say it goes down
traditionalist Chang isn't impressed but
more crucially what will the monks think
food would be not for today it's brought
to the monastery to serve to the monks
bang on 11 o'clock
good morning
Tam is a regular worshiper at the temple
where respect and etiquette are crucial
shoes yeah of course
my pad thai is separated into dishes and
joins the small portions of everyone's
food
every day all this food comes in right
donated donated in this wonderful Palace
so this is one tree
each trays for each monk for each month
look all that food Mr Chang doesn't like
my pad thai it doesn't taste very good
apparently
I guess I can see from the calories look
nice yeah exactly
the monks pray and chant before eating
this is a far cry from a service at
claridge's
now it's my turn but it's hard to tell
what they make of it
because if you offer food you're
forbidden to talk to the monks whilst
they're eating
something
excuse me thank you
I knew it was going to be you know
respectful and yeah brilliantly done but
it's very serious very serious it's
always like this always well always
to find out how well the pad thai went
down I spy in the monks to see if
they're enjoying it
Disneyland
how can you say my bad guys
look at that it's the most eaten Bowl
my pad thai seem to go down well but I
couldn't resist breaking the protocol by
asking the monks about the food
one very simple question did you enjoy
the pad thai yes
[Laughter]
experience takes respect for food to a
completely different level it's humbling
and a fascinating insight into Thai
Buddhist tradition
that was an amazing experience and it
was so nice to see such traditional Thai
culture here in the middle of Wimbledon
as for being a monk and eating my last
meal at 11 o'clock in the morning nah
thanks but no thanks
[Music]
right last table Yeah Moy table two
please yes
thank you
good well done
that's it
this case were amazing uh the sauce like
a sweet sassay sauce and complimented it
really well fish cakes were a little bit
rubbery but the flavors that and the
ingredients that went into them were
really good welcome dear friend really
good to see you how are you absolutely
yeah nervous
doing in there
you know she is the kind of person that
would would hit it right at the spot I'm
very confident so she can handle
pressure brilliantly and what do we mean
for you I'd leave here this evening as
victory you know for our area Stoke
Newington is very important for us
I love the presentation patient all laid
out beautifully beautiful little
dressing not your usual sweet chili
sauce dumped on the edge of the plate it
was too much spice in the Cod cakes and
in the end I didn't wasn't able to
recognize what else was in there welcome
to the earthquake really nice to see you
you work with Patrick a lot yes yes does
she shout in front of the customers
sometimes you just get out from the
restaurant this is my restaurant if the
some customers a bit rude or compared to
her yeah and she throws them out yeah
now what would it mean for her tonight
to leave the f word restaurant as a
winner she haul a lot she will get the
the winner
now yum yums are made with a great
feather back on prawns basically a Thai
freshwater fish
it's rather spongy
feel that little texture of a sort of
sponge when you press it with a fork and
simply tie again
quite
an interesting dressing love the color
texture wise
that's delicious it's less spongy
and sort of more robust
um both very delicious give me a tough
one to call if it was me I'd have to go
for Simply Thai
while the rest of the diners enjoy yum
yum and simply ties fish cakes here's my
take on this Classic Thai Dish
[Music]
start prepping the fish fillers of Coley
prawns red curry paste sugar
fish sauce salt
eggs caffeine Lime Leaf coriander lid on
pulse
French beans
shape just flatten it down a little bit
chill cucumber relish
chopped cucumber shallot chili lime
dressing coriander and mint hot pan
vegetable fried
they smell delicious
drain
[Applause]
[Music]
Thai fish cakes with cucumber relish
done
so all the diners have finished their
starters and the results are in now they
are tough customers out there how well
do you think you did I'm happy very very
happy out of 25 customers how many do
you think are happy to pay for that
oh oh
wow I love that ah Moy yeah how many do
you think out of 25
25 out of 25. what's with the conference
between you guys it's amazing okay let's
find out the results JB thank you
let's start off with Simply Thai yeah
the amount of customers they're happy to
pay for your delicious fish cakes out of
25 is
21 out of 25 that's amazing
that is amazing
that's very good huh
what didn't they like the four guests um
slightly overcooked couldn't taste as
well the fish okay don't show those four
customers to Petro she'll kick them out
okay very good start are you happy thank
you yeah are you happy I'm very happy
good I'm glad you're happy so you should
be now
moyony your heart is pounding okay let's
see the number of customers out of 25
willing to pay for Yum Yum's fish cake
yeah is
22 out of 25 well done
well done
that is incredible really well done
22 out of 25.
both fantastic skills yum yum you're now
one point in the lead thank you stay
down and get ready for the main courses
it can all change yes on this main
course okay well done next on the menu
with yum yum and Simply Thai virgin neck
and neck could this be the closest
contest yet good luck there's only one
point in it
Rory Bremer takes me on in the recipe
Challenge and he's brought David
blunkett for backup don't pat the dog I
love your [__] adults
[Applause]
[Music]
Now 50 portions each you can do this
good luck there's only one point in it
yes yes okay let's go right simply tie
pulled pork curry let's go thank you yum
yum four chicken curry no one's
answering me
cooking the main course first up is
Simply Thai
Trio wear a pan is an incredible driving
force behind simply tying Teddington
[Music]
since I was
sort of the people here very faithful
regulars patria's amazing work ethic is
matched only by her passion for the food
she serves every dish is on the menu is
my favorite
spicy pork please
Simply Thai singer this night is spicy
sweet pork to make a paste petria
finally Cuts lemongrass chops galangal
similar to Ginger but it's much more
subtle pearls and slices of the skin of
a Thai lime garlic coriander root and
Thai shallots the smell of the aroma is
much
she adds red chili black pepper and
crispy pork fat and grinds to a fine
paste in a petal and mortar I learned to
make
about 13 or 14 years old I had to sit on
the floor and my hand that time was so
small and this is big and it's really a
hard work for a little girl
you fries the pork loin and puts aside
in a saucepan she fries off the paste
adds coconut cream and the fried pork
loin
next she adds steamed pork belly palm
sugar white sugar
some fish sauce and chopped fine green
beans
[Music]
she says with deep-fried salty duck egg
and a salad with sweet Thai dressing
service please
Spicy Sweet Pork served
good
now tell me about the recipe what's it
good about it it's quite a complex
they're very very complex and they're
hard working it took me
six hours last night just to make the
curry paste because we have to use pesto
and mortar well our God never came round
and knocked the door
yeah I said what are you doing what are
you banging I've never heard it before
are you dancing the something
no 10 o'clock 10 o'clock in the evening
in the evening did you throw him out yes
it did yeah good now yep you're one
point in the lead are you feeling
confident yes chef
pet Chef Moy has been serving up a
flavor of Thailand to Yum Yum in North
London for almost 20 years I've been to
Thailand quite a few times and it's most
probably the nearest I would get to it
absolutely fantastic from starters right
through to dessert it's absolutely
amazing food has always been a huge part
of moi's life and she was trained to
cook the traditional Thai way
in Thailand yeah Thai girl in a family
must go to the kitchen
and learn how to cook
yum yum six of the dish tonight is red
chicken curry with plantain
Moy starts by peeling and slicing green
plantain
peels a green papaya and slices it
in time we have this our backyard
so we grew up with this
and easy to get and you don't have to
buy it next for the red curry paste she
cuts lemongrass finely chops gallon gal
the Rind of a Thai lime a coriander stem
and crushes garlic
going away
and she adds the seeded red chillies and
blends
she fries a red curry paste in a Hot Wok
for 10 minutes
she adds coconut cream fish sauce sugar
chopped chicken the plantain and papaya
she then Cooks it for five minutes
finally Moy adds red and green chilies
and Thai Sweet Basil
red chicken curry with plantain
served
[Music]
and my you're currently in the lead yeah
what do we mean for you to win tonight
very happy very happy what do we do for
the restaurant
party party
what other Thai restaurants you think
are good in London I don't know yum yum
wow wow wow oh wow what makes yours
stand apart I'm quite confident that my
food is good right Patrick yes you ever
been to Nam the mission star Thai
restaurant
I've been several times do you enjoy it
yes I did fantastic food yeah and Moy
have you ever been to Nam no I haven't
been there no never heard of it I've
heard of it yes do you think it'd be the
second so I wanted to get a mission of
style yes it will be soon soon I like
that compliments Patrick yes chef what
does your husband think about your food
I'm sure you are but would you like me
to introduce you to a nice young French
boy
no no thank you okay no sorry JB Patrick
said no she wants someone a little bit
younger you're too big
what's the matter
she what she angry she's angry yeah
watch out don't make her angry otherwise
we're all screwed are you demanding with
men as much as you are in your kitchen
no compromise no compromise yeah seven
please
Patriot yes seriously when was your last
day off uh last Easter Sunday Last
Easter Sunday yes oh my God so you don't
take Sunday Monday off as your days off
no can't afford it you're amazing you
are an iron lady
bloody good job
done that's a good life I like that
the chicken was very well cooked it was
well presented because the rice was out
of the bowl which was a lot more easy to
consume as well he had the classic kind
of Thai Taste to it but the only thing
that really didn't work for me was the
plantain it was a little bit hard a
little bit Bland the Paul Woods cooked
very well it's very tender nicely thinly
sliced the actual Curry itself is quite
greasy and a lot of the meat it was
quite fatty and I found the rice to be a
bit cold so I was a bit a bit unhappy
with this course
right simply ties pork curry very
authentic put cork twice slow roasted
and then a loin of pork sauteed
finished
flavor is amazing texture delicious not
too hot but a real nice depth of flavor
this is a very authentic pork curry
absolutely phenomenal yum yums
that's the kind of color you'd expect in
a chicken curry
there's such a difference a huge
contrast Simply Thai taste and looks
authentic
yum yum comes across mainstream and not
that exciting I would imagine that the
diners would prefer the authenticity of
Simply Thai with only one point between
the teams it couldn't be tighter okay
let's find out the results uh John
Baptist please okay let's go Simply Thai
first yeah so bearing in mind but they
are a tough tough bunch of diners this
evening
the number of customers are happy to pay
out of 50.
is
wow
39 out of 50. well done huh that's
really good really good indeed that's a
great score
39.
9 your feedback they Define the meat a
bit too fatty they found the meat a
little bit too fatty would you like to
throw out the 11 people that are not
going to pay for it
um no no okay because they have still
deserves a good thing exactly well done
39.50 pretty good okay yum yum the
number of donors that are happy to pay
for your chicken curry yeah
is
is wow
23.
that's a bit of a shock okay rjb the
main problem was too spicy too spicy
spicy they find a portion as well not
balanced somewhere big somewhere smaller
it's not over yet you can't pull this
back it has happened before yeah lay
down and let's go for the dessert right
damn there's a shot
now time for the recipe challenge we got
everything here restaurants yes
cameraman yes chef yes celebrities yes
ingredients yes let's [__] do it
it's good to see you oh we don't need
this now what are you cooking I'm gonna
do a trifold it is so simple to do
because you know you're not I can see
you know faffing around with eggs and
yolks and vanilla pods and all that sort
of stuff I mean this is just sponge
fingers lemon curd and liqueur and
you're off right so you're making trifle
okay I'm making my version of a trifle
now shouldn't you be doing the custard
first or you're doing the sponge first
uh no doing the sponge for uh actually
that's a good point probably if I did
the cream first how does this work
oh we've got this
normally if you're doing it for six
people yes you would need half a liter
of double cream just over 100 grams 120
grams of caster sugar that is quite a
lot of sugar trifle's not exactly
cutting edges it's something you
remember from your childhood uh yeah
well childhood with Scottish childhood
like yours then when we were children I
mean it was about getting as much
cholesterol as you could in two kids
yeah until they died wasn't it it was
massive it was meat pies it was haggis
slice cream so Roy's doing his version
of his trifle I'm gonna do exactly the
same this time and use panettone first
I'm going to make a really nice
delicious custard now this is the fun
part this is the Cointreau you sprinkle
a little bit over there if I was doing
Keith Floyd a little bit over there and
quite a lot in here
right okay very very good they're all
wonderful don't forget Pink Floyd very
very sadly Miss he was a man who
invented all that thing that Gordon is
so good at which is of course swearing
on television right okay how are we
doing right where's the cream going
round round you see this is the thing
your voice is hard to do because you
lost the Scottish accent just you think
is that difficult to do yeah you can get
a bit there's a little bit of Birmingham
in there but I don't I just you know I
kind of listened to you and I've tried
I've studied you I've done you in shows
what works is the makeup is that I mean
it takes an hour and a half that'd be
you the scars an hour and a half or two
how do you do that every morning yes
your forehead looks like mine already
come on I do I know we are the before
advert in the botox have you ever seen
it uh I'm gonna put some lemon juice
into this to make some lemon custard
okay how old when you first started
doing impressions uh about uh eight or
nine I used to watch my yard a lot
during my yard yeah and he was if he is
the first person to do Bob man Castle
he used to love me Bob and um David
Attenborough all of those in front of
your parents yeah yeah it's got any
impressions of people alive uh it's
ghetto yes I do we have David blancett
did you last year on the f word yeah
what did he cook
five but he was always so aggressive
David
don't pat the dog I love your [__]
head off
no today I'll be launching Daft
legislation no sorry I'll read that
again
draft legislation how long does it take
you you perfected Blair Bush Well that
took me about yeah 12 years I think yeah
George Bush we miss you know he went it
was the end of an error so now we have
Obama can you do he's cool
he's authoritative and um just want to
say he speaks
slowly if there is anyone out there
who still doubts we haven't got time to
do the whole thing can you do an
impression of Obama
tonight
now the custard's thickened
great A Touch of the orange zest in
there that makes it nice and light
fragrant less rich
the panettone
slice nice and thinly not too thick
and then cut the slices in half and
spread with a little thick cut marmalade
and then from there
slice that down into cubes little touch
of Grand Marnier
on top
it's got really nice
rich
flavor running through and then from
there can I watch you because my recipe
means I've got loads of time from there
thing is Ryan I'm going to beat you this
is not a race it's about perfection you
know how competitive I am huh now right
there and then Brian takes a little
bigger winner feeling confident uh yes
yeah I think I hope that is the fridge
isn't it yeah it's definitely the best
I've just put it in the dishwasher in
the dishwasher cycle two 25 minutes
fantastic lovely clean taste
next on the menu will Patria be able to
maintain her lead all the cool calm yum
yum girls be able to pull off a comeback
this is the most important course of the
night and one of you is going to come
out as the winner
and will Rory Bremer's trifle make a
good impression we'll find out the
winner of the recipe challenge come on
who don't do this to me I hate it when
you've got that smoke
[Applause]
[Music]
now welcome back to the f word time for
the results of the recipe challenge
ready yes absolutely excited yes very
now what is that you put on top of that
what are they uh this is crystallized
violets Violet petals so you've got
silver balls uh I have on the trifle on
top of the trifle I'm finishing my cream
with a bit of lemon zest just to give
that a little bit of a wake up and then
grating some chocolate on there no
chocolate orange lemon
all right ready mine doesn't look as
flash as yours yeah yeah one for kids
and one for adults oh yeah that is no
right JB good oh no put your fingers in
there don't drop those yeah those balls
way heavier than you
hi everyone here we go
[Music]
there's a Tang to it but it's quite
subtle I like the lemon I actually think
that is really nice the lemon flavor is
really nice
very different actually completely
different but this is very vanilla it's
quite sweet actually as well okay
results uh right JB oh no he's got that
French Mercury what do they think of
both the Trifles they really like both
of them what the silver balls yeah they
really like it what were the scores
fantastic
excellent that's a hammering now please
leave my kitchen oh he's lining up
it's been a pleasure it's been
absolutely
thank you yes five nil fantastic
now back to the competition and it's
time for dessert both Thai brigades will
be cooking my recipe
[Music]
lime and coconut rice pudding an Asian
Twist on a traditional rice pudding
first off right into the pan
400 milliliters of coconut milk 80 grams
of caster sugar
vanilla pod what the vanilla pod does to
the rice is helps to really perfume and
make it really nice and fragrant simmer
for 20 minutes
hot pan desiccated coconut
so the coconut really helps to bring out
that nice nutty flavor
when the rice is tender add 150
milliliters of double cream the toasted
coconut
and chopped mango
fold it in
[Music]
top with mango
pistachio
toasted coconut finish the rice with a
little grating fresh lime beautiful Thai
mango lime and coconut rice pudding
done
uh yeah this is the most important
course for you of the night you can pull
this one back yes yep yep yeah yeah good
I'll do my best in here there's only 25
more plates each yes it got to be
perfect yeah they have to be perfect and
one of you is going to come out as the
winner
if Simply Thai win tonight it will mean
everything to Patria I would be so
excited it's just like a dream comes
true and for yum yum victory means the
massive restaurant will be fully booked
for months to come all my local customer
they'll be very proud
what kind of desserts do you have at
Simply Thai coconut creme brulee and
it's recipes but I substitute I changed
the milk to Coconut so it's my recipe
for Creole but you put coconut in there
yeah careful Montana if you keep on
pasting it it's going to break it up and
it'll end up in the bowl yeah like
wallpaper paste
so this is interesting unfortunately Moy
has dropped her confidence and sort of
become very very quiet on the other hand
Petra has sort of raised the bar and she
wants to really make sure this rice
pudding is absolutely perfect and she's
having fun with it as well
foreign
I can't believe you're this happy you
haven't won yet
yeah
I'm just about to put two two portions
of sugar in one pan
oh no I haven't done that sir
not yet
Montana
yeah the rice is ready so if it sits
there longer it's overcooked yeah
moisten everything try to get a system
going you put the rice in you put the
pistachios on you put the mango on you
put the lime on okay yep
dessert was absolutely lovely
um 10 out of 10. absolutely delicious I
think it's amazing I think yeah with the
the mango the fresh mango as well yeah
we happy I thought the rice pudding was
delicious I thought the mango was
perfect the coconut you could really
taste it the consistency of the mango
and the lime you know amazing there we
go all finished
right desserts simple fragrant Thai rice
pudding my recipe but have they done it
um yum yums
nice the unfortunate thing is the rice
is slightly pasty a little bit
overcooked
simply tie
hmm rice is perfectly cooked that is
delicious
yeah I like that
time to find out who's going to be
crammed the F word's best local Thai
restaurant okay time for the results uh
JB please so thank you
let's start off with yum yum okay okay
the amount
of customers they're happy to pay for
dessert out of 25
is
17 out of 25. that's amazing
it's amazing
well done
and you didn't give up well done thank
you really good okay simply time the
number of customers that are happy to
pay for your dessert out of 25
is
damn
22 out of 25.
that means in total you have 82 out of
100.
congratulations really really well done
Montana well done I'm enjoying it now do
me a big favor yes get out of it and get
yourself a big drink congratulations
ladies and gentlemen yum yum
oh I enjoyed it very much and on top of
that I got this that proof isn't it that
um you know if you put your heart and
soul into everything you work you're
gonna you can achieve
simply tie a joint top of the f word
leaderboard with the top six brigades
guaranteed a place in the next round
their stunning performance means they go
through to the semi-finals
[Music]
culinary treat the F word's best local
Spanish restaurant
will your favorite be joining me in the
f word kitchen
will Kelly Brook crack as she takes me
on in the recipe challenge
and I'll be in Northwest Spain risking
my life in search of an extraordinary
delicacy all that [__] work for these
things